تتواصل اعماله قمه العشرين في جزيره باليه
لاندونيسيه بمشاركه 17
رئيس دوله وتبحث القمه ازمه الطاقه في ظل
استمرار الحرب في اوكرانيا
ويتوقع ان تتبنى اتفاقا يعزز مبادئ التحول
الى الطاقه النظيفه
وتقدم اندونيسيا التي تستضيف القمه مسوده
لخارطه طريق ترسخ التعاون بين الدول في
مجال تحويل الطاقه والاستجابه للتحديات
التي تواجه الدول الناميه
هذا ورفض وزير الخارجيه الروسيه سيرجيله
بروب ما سماها محاولات ادانه روسيا في
البيان الختامي لمجموعات العشرين وقال في
مؤتمر صحفي ان مساوره البيان الختامي لقمه
مجموعه العشرين تشمل كل من التقييمات
الغربيه والروسيه للوضع في اوكرانيا واضاف
ان الغرب اخفق في لون روسيا على فشل
التوصل الاتفاق على بيان ختاميا لاعمال
هذه القمه